a la una de la tarde hora de Washington
el comité que Investiga lo que ocurrió
El Seis de enero del 2021 cuando se
trataron de meter y de tomar el
Capitolio se reunirá por última vez
después de dieciocho meses de
investigaciones y pues no solamente
discutirá los últimos hallazgos de esta
investigación sino que también va a
referir a Donald Trump a el departamento
de Justicia referirlo por cargos después
de esta investigación de insurrección de
obstrucción a un proceso legal en el
congreso y también por conspirar para
defraudar a Estados Unidos esto sin
embargo hay que aclarar no tiene efectos
legales para el expresidente Donald
Trump lo que sí invita el congreso al
departamento de Justicia es pues a
considerar la investigación que lleva
siendo ya por dieciocho meses hay que
recordar también que el departamento de
Justicia ya empezó por cuenta propia su
propia investigación en contra del
expresidente Trump y sus vínculos toma
el territorio y otra de las aristas
sobre las investigaciones por la toma
del Capitolio es lo que ocurre con el
grupo extremista prau Boys que hoy
precisamente se conformará el Jurado
para el juicio del presidente del
movimiento Enrique tario entre otros
cuatro miembros que sigue en este caso
exactamente los fiscales además de
nombrar un Jurado van a presentar los
cargos los fiscales Pues argumentan que
enriquetario y los trollboys pues usaron
la masa que caminó desde la casa blanca
de la Plaza de la libertad hasta el
Capitolio como un arma un arma para
interferir el proceso legal de traspaso
de poder lo que dicen analistas es que
pues hubieran podido acusarlos
simplemente de
lo que acá en Estados Unidos se conoce
como entrar a un edificio público sin
necesidad pero no los quieren acusar de
Conspiración sediosa